hey everyone welcome to yet another
exciting video from simply learn in this
session we will be discussing
competitive programming however before
we begin the session let's look at the
agenda for today's topic
first we begin with learning what
competitive programming is after that we
shall understand why we need competitive
programming
later we shall focus on tips to learn
competitive programming and finally we
will wind up the session by discussing
the benefits of learning competitive
programming
i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda but before we begin let me tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple technologies so if you're a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
now let's get started with what
competitor programming is
competitive programming is a spot
perhaps even a form of art
which generally involves the host
presenting a set of logical or
mathematical problems also known as
puzzles to the contestants required to
write computer programs capable of
solving each problem
judging is mainly based on the number of
problems solved and the time spent
writing successful solutions
still it may also include other factors
like quality of output produced
execution time program size etc
it is also an activity that requires
creativity and analytical thinking to
tackle complex coding problems
competitive programming includes events
usually held over the internet where
participants call sports programmers
solve specific problems or puzzles
competitive programming is supported and
conducted by several multinational
software and internet companies for
examining the person before the
recruitment of the employees
competitive programming also includes
presenting logical or mathematical
problems and puzzles
judging usually done by host machines is
generally based on the number of
problems solved under a time constraint
the goal is to write source code that
involves a logical or mathematical
problem
now let's have a look at why we need
competitive programming
competitive programming helps in
providing better career opportunities
and helps to build excellent
professional careers competitor
programming helps to get more experience
over coding programming and helps to
solve and build good knowledge on
programming
competitive programming also helps build
problem solving skills in a person and
makes a person solve programming
problems quite easily
competitive programming is one of the
reasons behind creative technology it
involves more opportunities for people
and programmers to develop new skills
now let's understand some of the tips to
learn competitive programming
before we are ready to start competitive
programming we must understand the
concepts once we understand the concepts
clearly we can start competitive
programming and solve it easily
so starting from the basics is the
better option to learn to program
if we want to solve the problems
practicing more and more is better once
we start practicing the concepts it is
easy to understand and solve further
quite easily
once we start practicing on daily life
problems and real time projects it helps
to solve the problems
be updated with the technologies and
programming languages as they hold a key
role in learning coding and programming
finally let's have a look at the
benefits of competitive programming
taking part in competitive programming
teaches you how to be more focused on
the task and not only complete it
quickly but also accurately
these skills are highly beneficial for
any job not just encoding
it also helps to solve complicated
problems
while you're training you will also
learn how to solve these out of the
ordinary tasks
this helps prepare you for a job because
you can adapt and solve various types of
problems in multiple situations
participating in a coding competition is
something you should highlight on your
assuming having experience in
competitive programming shows employers
you can work in a team solve complicated
problems work in stressful situations
manage time and deadlines and minimize
errors
competitive programming helps you learn
how to effectively work together as you
must work with others on your team to
complete the same task
you'll learn how to assess your team
members strengths and weaknesses and
effectively divide responsibilities
between each other
and this was all for today's session i
hope now you guys have an idea of how
important competitive programming is in
these days
if you have any questions would you
please let us know in the comment
section below we have our experts to
answer them as early as possible
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here